22 berceau supplémentaire c'est
l'objectif de la nouvelle crèche de la
verrière en cours de construction un
projet à 2 5 millions d'euros financés
par la ville en grande partie mais aussi
par la caisse d'allocations familiales
des yvelines et le département on
augmente quand même notre nombre de
berceaux à 22 pour passer à 45 berceau
au total aussi en pour regrouper les
différentes structures de la ville dans
un unique emplacement pour être plus
performant dans l'accueil des enfants et
des familles c'était une vraie demande
une vraie impatience même des familles
avec des horaires qui seront au maximum
adaptés aux horaires de travail des
parents pourrait que le plus
facilitateur possible ce nouvel
équipement regroupera les deux
microcrèches ainsi que la crèche
familiale située sur le terrain de
l'ancienne protection maternelle et
infantile
la nouvelle crèche fera 700 m² au total
et une volonté de travailler sur
vraiment le volet environnemental
puisque on est parti pour acquérir la
certification hqe eux donc haute qualité
environnementale et pour ça on a
travaillé sur toute l'isolation du
bâtiment sur les énergies renouvelables
pour toute la partie chauffage et
traitement d'air donc on a aujourd'hui
un équipement qui est vraiment moderne
et intégrée dans son nouvel
environnement
ouverture pour la prochaine rentrée en
septembre 2021
les inscriptions ne sont pas encore
ouvertes mais la municipalité la sur les
45 berceau seront attribués dans les
plus brefs délais